- Are you kidding me?
That looks great.
Sorry, I'll clean you up, but like...
(record scratch sound)
Oh my god.
(upbeat music)
Hello, everyone.
My name is Tucker,
and welcome to my tiny messy kitchen.
Look at this thing.
I'm also, I'm a big guy,
so I mean, maybe it would
be less tiny for you,
but come on now, look.
Ready? I'm opening.
It's so tiny.
So a little backstory about
me and this household.
I am the messy roommate,
and my roommate is very, very clean.
So he has challenged me
to utilize the space
in a way that makes us both happy.
So he has challenged me
to transform the kitchen
by using techniques,
hacks, items I found online,
to make the kitchen more usable and clean.
And you know what?
Make this tiny kitchen work for us.
Ugh.
You can't see the sink, right?
Hey, camera op!
No. That is off limits.
It is time we transform this kitchen
into something that is
beautiful and utile.
Is that the word?
Okay, let's get started.
So when poking around online,
something I consistently saw
was to use shelves.
Okay, we're not working
with much space here,
but we got a lot of vertical space here.
Look at this, right?
Okay.
So as much as this affirmation wall,
to-do list, photo wall
has been nice to look at,
it's time to get rid of it,
throw up some shelves.
Let's get rid of this affirmation wall.
Sorry, mom,
you're out.
(upbeat music)
Okay. The shelves are up.
I mean, they're looking sturdy as ever.
That'll hold a small child.
I did need a little help
from producer Mike.
Thank you.
It was a little more labor
intensive than expected.
Hopefully, that's the hardest
thing we'll be doing today.
Let's make sure that these actually,
this does work.
I don't know. I don't trust myself, but...
Come on, now.
This is heavy, too.
Could only do so many reps of these.
So that works.
That looks great.
Okay, let's try some other things.
So I found online
these magnetic spice holders.
Look at this.
Are you kidding me?
I can't get enough.
It also came with these little labels.
You got everything here.
You got all-purpose, allspice, caraway.
Not quite sure what that one is.
I don't have all of those,
but I do have my spices here
from this messy cabinet.
So this is gonna clear up a lot of space.
I'm thinking line them here,
because then this thing opens with ease.
Let's add some more.
What should we do?
Okay, ground cinnamon for sure, next,
'cause I'm starting with
the ones that I use often.
And by often, I mean once a year,
'cause I never cook.
I'm obsessed with this.
Okay, let's talk knives.
This is the current knife sitch.
It's a free-for-all.
We just throw the cutting
knives and stuff in here.
We got a whisk in here.
We got a knife in here.
So that needs to change.
The steps to fix that
would be a knife block,
but no.
We can't have that now, can we?
Because where's the counter space?
So, a fun solution,
going back to our magnetic theme,
is a little magnetic knife bar.
Slap this bad boy on the fridge
and now we can start hanging up
some of our loose knives,
because we're adults
and that's what an adult would do.
That's not... Hold on.
Okay, that part sticks.
There you go.
Look at that.
If I have eyes on the knives,
I can be careful,
but when they're in here,
I don't have eyes on them.
Who knows what they're gonna do?
That's fantastic. I'm loving this.
Okay, it's time to go under the sink.
Our current situation under the sink
is kind of just
throw it under there,
close it, and forget about it.
So that probably has to change.
We have a couple things that we can do
that we're working with.
We have a little overhang basket.
We have a little Command.
Oh my god.
If I didn't break it, we have
a little Command strip basket
that also can be placed.
Then we also have a
little extra storage area,
and get this.
Ready for this? Ready to be blown away?
Oh, wait. Oh, I'm
holding it the wrong way.
A little slide-out storage.
I think that my method here
is gonna be, "What do we use
the most under this sink?
What do we not use a lot?"
Because the dishwasher is right here,
I slap this over here.
What if?
Like what if?
Okay, so now, in here...
Look. Again, we're working
with that vertical space now.
Come on!
Literally stop.
Everyone stop. Stop rolling.
Are you kidding me?
I have an idea.
I have an idea. Stick with me.
Here we go.
Um.
The two things I use most.
Dishwasher. Getting the trash bag.
1,000% not what that's for,
but it works for me
and my household, okay?
So that's what we're gonna do.
Okay, I'm gonna put the little caddy up.
Give me like four hours.
(mellow music)
This is incredible.
Look at the amount of
space I have in there now.
So much space, I could
throw a party for 10.
So, in an effort to clean
up our silverware drawer
that had a bunch of measuring cups
kind of laying about,
we thought,
"Hey, why not work with a hooker too?"
(record scratch sound)
Okay?
A hook or two.
That...
Sorry about that.
So here we have
a wonderful six-hooked thing.
My vision is to slap this up here,
stick it down,
and just kind of have these things dangle.
And then look at this. Ready? Ready?
(objects clattering)
It'll...
It'll be stuck in there.
So obviously, that won't happen.
But, I mean, that just
clears up some space.
And it's cute.
If you're wearing socks,
you might want to
preemptively take them off,
'cause they're about to be blown off.
We got it at IKEA.
Ready for this?
It's like an accordion.
(mimics accordion sounds)
You may be thinking, "What
in the world could that be?"
It's to hold your pot lids.
So our current method is kind of
what some would call a scavenger hunt.
It's a free-for-all.
It's a graveyard, even.
I'm thinking we line
up in ascending order,
just because that is so slay to do.
It would probably look better
with your matching pot set.
But you know what?
That's okay.
Play with how big or small you want it.
I'm gonna drop all of these
and they're gonna break.
So I'm gonna put this down.
Night and day.
Oh, that looks fantastic.
So it has come to my attention
that I have the wrong
storage things in here.
I'm pretty sure that I've been using
your classic fork, spoon,
knife holder thing in here.
No wonder nothing fits.
That's not the right storage thing.
We got a new storage container,
and I'm thinking that
this one will work better,
because it actually has
room to put stuff in it
as opposed to this.
Like what?
Sorry. Sorry.
I'll clean you up.
But like...
Oh my god.
We're good.
We're gonna put this thing in here.
Then that way, now we have some space
to put our oven mitts
and then we also have space
to put our actual utensils.
I can't wait to show my roommate.
This poor poor space, cupboard,
needs a little love, too, people.
It is a nightmare in there.
Look at this. Ready?
Ah!
So we're gonna free up that room right now
with a shelf.
Stuff can go under, stuff can go on top,
stuff can go to the side.
Where to start?
My goodness.
Half of this video, I feel like,
is me just realizing I don't need
half of the stuff in these cupboards.
So I just have to throw it out.
Oh my god, that's so much oil.
So gross.
Look at that!
Okay, so we're gonna put
this stuff now in here.
So organized!
So organized.
Maybe I'll put stuff
that I've literally never
looked at in my life
maybe towards the back.
I might get more shelves,
because why not?
I mean, look at that.
I went from boom, boom, boom
to boom, boom, boom, boom.
I have a real treat for everyone now.
Look at this space.
Dead. Empty, even.
So why not put a little cart?
Maybe it's on wheels, maybe it's not.
What we have here is wonderful.
"Why?" you ask.
We have some counter space.
We have some drawers.
I mean, world's your oyster.
It doesn't matter how you're opening it.
It opens on both sides.
Slap this bad boy right over here.
Now that we have our little cart here,
we're gonna deck it out with some goodies.
(upbeat music)
We have a couple cutting
boards in our household,
but this,
oh, my, I mean, you
could snap this in half.
They're not quality.
They're kind of small.
I invested in a quality cutting board
that also maximizes the space.
So this thing can hang over the sink.
So, you know, you're washing
your strawberries, right?
And boom, you're doing that over here.
Boom, boom, bang.
Or maybe you're chopping up some tomatoes.
You got so much juice everywhere.
You need to slide that baby off.
Oh, you don't want this here?
Get rid of it.
This thing is so cool,
'cause look at this.
Ready? Ready?
That is so much.
Okay, so I love this.
It's basically like a
little Tupperware vibe.
Something you could store stuff in.
And I love that it's expandable.
Oh, wait a minute.
Okay, ready?
Yep. Okay.
So maybe you want a
little big opening here
and then a little drainage also.
Do whatever the gosh darn
heck you want, people,
because this thing is so versatile.
So I was just asked where
my baking sheets are,
and I was like, "Where
are they? Where are they?"
And I remembered
we put them in the oven.
And then it came to my attention,
I was informed that
I have this storage under here.
That's what that is for.
I was just... I don't...
I can't even tell you what I was thinking,
because I don't know what I was thinking.
I wasn't thinking.
An easy cool trick
to really maximize your space.
Now, I don't have to worry
about burning my hands off
every time I go to get a baking sheet.
Easy peasy.
Well, there you have it.
This has been a long day,
I will admit.
This place was a mess before.
I think that we used a lot of fun methods
and just general cleaning up the space,
as well as adding a few fun flairs.
I mean, come on!
I think we did a great job.
I do think that my roommate
is going to be very pleased with me.
So let me know what
your favorite part was,
which of these methods you want to use,
which of these methods
you already use currently.
And hey, any methods I missed,
because Lord knows I
missed a lot, I'm sure.
There's so many things out there.
So let me know.
Have a good one, everyone.
(blowing kisses)
(upbeat music)